a woman can marry a man leave him for
any reason she wants even after cheating
on him and still take half the assets
and be awarded with an allowance from
her ex-husband in perpetuity it's not
only outrageously unjust but it also
purposefully in disincentivizes marital
Fidelity while incentivizing disloyalty
and infidelity and divorce there are
many reforms that should be enacted to
stop the bleeding here the alimony
system for one thing has to be
drastically changed most alimony laws
were created under the assumption that
most women would be Housewives and they
would be stay-at-home moms and most
divorces would be initiated by men who
are the sole Breadwinners in the family